a Golgi apparatus the most amazing thing
about this is Alex true love is going to
have sex next week huh hot sweaty
intercourse of a sexual kind oh my name
is Alex true love yes that's my real
name
I have a 4.0 GPA I'm student body
president and I have a great girlfriend
you're coming with us to this party and
you're gonna let your little constipated
hair down and enjoy yourself one join
the cool kids
I think we're here to corrupt you Alex
[Music]
so I have a girlfriend
I know oh she's adorable Cheers there's
this guy who I'm pretty sure has a crush
on me
and I guess I'm not repulsed by the idea
look it's a confusing time man
everywhere you look someone is
omnisexual or transitioning how did you
know you were gay how do you know you're
straight
[Music]
what's going on I'm trying to do purge
minds you for the past eight months you
won't let me it's like Mad Max out here
guys he's doing guys girls doing girls
girls turning into guys and doing girls
that used to do girls in guys ah
I'm over at Dell this whole thing sex
love I'm out can someone please explain
modern high school boys to me
are you so scared of
love is strange
[Music]
you